we started to use the term marijuana
mainly to associate it with mexican
americans
in an effort to vilify the drug because
cannabis had been around forever
and many americans were familiar with
the effects of cannabis
and so you couldn't make these
incredible stories up about cannabis
itself
but really they're the same thing
i'm carl hart professor in the
departments of psychiatry and psychology
at columbia university i study the
effects of drugs
in people there's so much
misunderstanding about drugs
particularly recreational drugs and
today i'd like to clear up some of the
information
and debunk many of the myths that many
people
hold marijuana is a gateway drug
when we say gateway drug we mean that
using marijuana
will cause someone to go on to use
so-called harder drugs
like cocaine or heroin when we think
about the people who
use heroin more of those people have
used marijuana beforehand that's
certainly true but when we look at
marijuana users in total the vast
majority of marijuana users
do not go on to use cocaine or heroin or
any other drug
so this notion that marijuana is a
gateway drug
confuses correlation with causation
correlation are just variables that may
go together if it's raining outside you
may see
more umbrellas that go up than when it's
not raining and that's a correlation
between
umbrellas and rainfall but no one would
say the umbrellas are
causing the rain that's correlation
causation is when you have a variable
that causes
another variable for example the last
three presidents
of the united states bill clinton george
bush
and barack obama all smoked marijuana
when they were young men it would be
like saying
that marijuana is a gateway drug to the
white house
it's not true that's the difference
between correlation
and causation we know for sure that
marijuana is not a gateway drug
because the vast majority of marijuana
smokers
never go on to using any other drugs
if it was a gateway drug then we would
have
the majority if not all going on
to try harder drugs pcp
gives superhuman strength one of the
ways
pcp acts on the brain is that it
interacts with a neurotransmitter called
glutamate
glutamate is the brain sort of major
excitatory neurotransmitter
it causes actions and pcp blocks
one of the glutamate receptors so it
prevents glutamate from
acting at that receptor when people
actually give pcp
to research participants in the lab you
have never seen anything remotely
resembling
super human strength or any of the other
sort of effects that have been
attributed to pcp
like aggression or violence this notion
that pcp
causes superhuman strength comes largely
from
police reports of police stories police
anecdotes
where you may have heard them say that
they have to shoot someone 28 times in
order to bring them under control
there is absolutely no evidence of that
can any of these illegal drugs induce
violence and the answer is
emphatically yes in people who are
already violent
but in general the drugs themselves are
not producing violence
drugs are more addictive than alcohol to
be clear
alcohol itself is a drug many of the
criteria
that determine whether or not someone is
addicted
depend upon the legality of the drug
you have to hide cocaine use because
that's not as socially acceptable
as alcohol so all of that impacts
whether or not someone becomes addicted
to a drug
once people become addicted to alcohol
versus something like cocaine or
something like heroin
if they stop abruptly taking alcohol
they can experience alcohol withdrawal
and alcohol withdrawal
can lead to seizures which can cause
convulsions
brain damage and ultimately death
when they withdraw from something like
cocaine
you don't get any of these physical
effects that
can cause death the same is true with
something like heroin
heroin doesn't cause death upon
withdrawal
only alcohol of these drugs can
cause death upon withdrawal if
withdrawal is not
done in a medical setting that is with
someone who
is heavily dependent on alcohol the
opioid crisis is getting worse
well that's not true in fact i would
even
suggest that we were not experiencing
a crisis of opioids instead we were
experiencing a crisis of
ignorance whenever we talk about the
opioid crisis we have to
differentiate what we mean are we
talking about
deaths related to opioids or are we
talking about addiction
related to opioids if we think about
addiction
the vast majority of people who use
opioids uh particularly
say prescription opioids a very low
percentage of people
become addicted something like heroin
where you have the higher
sort of addiction rates and that's about
a third at most
that's not necessarily a crisis because
very low number of people use heroin
when we think about the overdose crises
that we want to call it that we've seen
numbers in the united states as high as
000 people dying from opioids every year
and that's just not true
the largest the amount of people who die
from a opioid related drug is maybe 45
000 per year that's at its peak but when
you even go
into that number what you discover
is that the vast majority of those
people
had another drug on board in addition to
an opioid some other drug like a
benzodiazepine
alcohol or antihistamine or something
else was on board so
whether or not the opioid actually
caused the death
we don't know marijuana doesn't have any
medicinal use
the federal government has a medical
marijuana program
in which small numbers of people are
enrolled
such that they receive marijuana from
the federal government for free
every month in order to deal with some
medical element
ranging from things like glaucoma or
some pain
so marijuana has been shown in a number
of studies to increase food intake to
decrease
pain and a growing number of other
medical ailments are being tested for
example
components of marijuana have been shown
to be effective for
decreasing seizures cbd recently has
become
one of the most talked about compounds
in marijuana
we have known marijuana's effects for
at least 70 some years or so
in 1944 mayor laguardia in new york city
released an extensive study of
marijuana's effects
and basically conclude what we know now
marijuana doesn't lead to these
long-term
negative effects that people upset it
doesn't lead to violence
laguardia reported in 1944 drew that
conclusion
and it's the same conclusion that
research today
draws the federal government the bureau
of narcotics
in 1937 pushed for the ban of marijuana
in part because it was associated with
groups that we
don't like in the united states mexican
and black folks
it had nothing to do with marijuana's
pharmacology
by pushing for marijuana to be illegal
or
banned or outlawed what happened too was
that the bureau of narcotics budget
increased marijuana is illegal today
at the federal level for political
reasons
not pharmacological reasons there are so
many
drug myths out there and the myths
themselves do more harm
than the drugs most people don't
use drugs therefore they
don't know about drugs and
ignorance is determining how many people
think about these drugs in part because
these myths lead to bad policies
and these policies cause increased rates
of incarceration
and deaths not from the drugs but from
the policies can lead to the
dehumanization of advanced
stigmatization of people
[Music]